le scénario du pire a été imaginé pour
cet exercice de sécurité à l' usine de
traitement des eaux du siaap
il a été menée jeudi 6 mai par la
préfecture avec la direction du site et
les huit communes environnantes
hr saint germain en laye maisons
laffitte et conflans sainte honorine
pour la partie blinoise l'alertent
fictive a été lancée à 9 heures avec une
simulation précise un des potages un
nuage de chlore qui se forment une météo
défavorable et tournantes qui impacte
les huit communes environnantes
c'est ce qui était retenu notre objectif
nous c'était de tester la robustesse du
plan particulier d'intervention la
constitution du 100 dos opérationnelle
par la préfecture est déporté à maisons
laffitte en quarts en termes de
protection
et puis évidemment l'arrivée des secours
les pompiers dans un premier temps
blocage des axes pour le périmètre de
sécurité par la police dans un deuxième
temps le 3 juillet 2019 l'un des
bâtiments de ce site classé seveso à
hauts risques industriels prenait feu un
incendie d'origine électrique des eaux
usées sont alors relâché dans la seine
occasionnant une pollution du fleuve et
la mort de dizaines de milliers de
poissons est depuis la catastrophe un
comité de suivi a été mise en place avec
les communes environnantes
deux audits de sécurité également
réalisé deux ans après les faits cet
exercice devait vérifier la bonne
coordination des différents acteurs
cet exercice était un premier test
concluant je trouve un pour l'arrivée
des secours
pour la réactivité surtout des communes
les élus étaient au rendez-vous les
procédures pour les écoles y avait un
ehpad même qui a joué en tout cas ce
moment pour le lien ils ont bien réagi
les numéros sont les bompard mais on a
vraiment tester le socle ce sur quoi une
crise doit s'appuyer pour générer le
secours et la protection
un exercice majeur devrait être menée
l'an prochain sur place avec essais des
sirènes et confinement de la population